greenhouse gas emissions from our food
systems have increased by more than 10
in the last 30 years
today
they account for about one-third of all
man-made global greenhouse gas emissions
and include emissions of both carbon
dioxide and methane nitrous oxide and
fluorinated
gases the average person's food
consumption produces the emission of
nearly two and a half tons of carbon
dioxide equivalent per year
however there are big differences
depending on how people live
the food systems of those regions of the
world with the lowest emissions per
capita produce less than one tonne of
carbon dioxide per person per year
while the food systems of the highest
emitting regions produce more than five
times as much
land use and production are responsible
for about 70
of the emissions of the entire food
system
as countries develop energy use
industrial activities and waste
management increasingly determine the
emissions from their food systems
it is clear that there is no
one-size-fits-all solution
and local differences in the effects of
development and mitigation measures
throughout the food chain will need to
be understood
nevertheless solutions are to reduce
greenhouse gas emissions from food
systems will need to include the both
instruments that reduce emissions
throughout the food chain and also
measures that help the citizen to adapt
to more informed and sustainable diets
in industrialized regions including
europe
the global food system will therefore
need investments in energy efficiency
and decarbonization technologies to
reduce these emissions in addition to
land-based mitigation technologies such
as more efficient use of fertilizers
within and outside the farm gate
the european union farm-to-fork strategy
includes these aspects in order to
reduce the environmental and climate
impact of primary food production
we have analyzed the emissions from the
different stages of food production to
support the development of policy tools
for the transition to a more sustainable
and informed consumption pattern
moderate consumption of animal-based
foods is already part of some national
food-based dietary guidelines
effective policies to transform food
systems towards sustainability need to
be comprehensive and provide answers for
both economy and consumers with adequate
information
we need transparent robust data to
understand the complexity of our food
systems
the completeness of the edgar food
database is therefore an important
aspect for monitoring global food system
emissions as part of integrated
mitigation strategies